Я заработал около 6 млрд долларов. У
меня отняли всё: банк, месторождения,
девелоперской [музыка] компании. Когда
жизнь конкретно бьёт по лицу на отпуш,
человек может начать меняться.
95% бизнесов, которые я инициировал сам,
заканчивались банкротством.
>> С ума сойти.
>> Для достижения успеха [музыка] создайте
спрос на себя.
>> Возможности и ресурсы приходят через
людей. Искусственный интеллект должен
убрать все рутинные операции, которые не
имеют смысла с точки зрения человека.
>> Какой бы вы совет дали самому себе? Не
надо становиться кладбищем ненужных
знаний. Многие предприниматели уже
получили деньги [музыка] от фонда
немалого бизнеса.
>> Теперь твоя очередь. Альфабанк раздаст
100 млн руб. предпринимателям по всей
стране.
>> Деньги получат лучшие истории. Расскажи
о своём бизнесе на alfabank.ru.
[музыка]
Мы в Казахстане и сегодня разговор с
Маргуланом Сисимбаевым о будущем, о
стратегии и о принципах предпринимателя,
который всегда остаётся на коне.
>> Я хотел поделиться, как я первый раз про
вас узнал. Я, кажется, на Ютубе очень
давно наткнулся на видео, где идёт
какой-то человек такой азиатская
внешность, очень просто выглядящий, и
рассказывает какие-то истории, как он
продавал, а, какую-то компанию
крупнейшим телеком оператором и говорит:
"Ну, я там одним предложил 200 млн, а
потом другие пришли 300 млн". Я такой
думаю: "Это это это вообще кто?" Я
как-то так подписался, начал смотреть,
начал читать, и для меня вообще открылся
огромный мир вашей философии, вашего
опыта, такого притом сурового опыта,
который строился в в сурово года.
>> Вы же пастухом были вообще был в
сельской глубинке. По-русски толком не
говорил. Вырос в Ауле, закончил
казахскую школу, потом пошёл в армию,
отслужил, потом в университет. Закончил
университет, сразу начал заниматься
бизнесом. То есть человек без ресурсов
абсолютно и без связей. Ээ, ну,
>> то есть наследство никакого там родители
вам
>> нет. Отец огромно, мать Завстоловый, там
сельская интеллигенция. Смотри, вот
такие стартовые условия, да? Потом
происходит коллапс Советского Союза. Из
всех книг по развитию в то время мною
причитано было Теодор Драйзер, это
трилогия желаний, там финансист, стоик,
титан, по-моему, называется. Прочитал
это и больше понятия о бизнесе не было.
Ну, уже позже, когда я университет
заканчивал, я прочитал книгу Дейла
Карнеги. Вот это вся база. Но так как я
изначально к бизнесу относился больше
как исследователь, я всё время наблюдал,
наблюдал, какие инструменты работают,
какие нет, что работает, что нет, как
нужно, в каких ситуациях поступать. У
меня начало быстро получаться.
Банковский бизнес, телеком-бизнес, э,
потом купил месторождение, угольные,
нефтяные месторождения, строительство,
девелопмент. Это в 2007 году это был
пик. Я заработал около 6 млрд долларов.
Ну, совокупный капитал был где-то 5.РД
800, если быть точным. Каждый раз я
ловил тренды. У меня даже друзья
называют меня ловцом трендов. А почему
ловцом трендов? Потому что я заметил
давно уже заметил такой закон, что
деньги находятся там, где внимание. Я
начал следить на за тем, а что является
модом. И вот мои друзья смеются,
говорит, даже банки были на хайпе, ты
был там, ты был банкиром, был, когда
были мистер рождения на хайпе, ты был
там, когда девелопмент, ты был там.
Потом, когда после кризиса начали
уголовные дела, там преследования, ты
опять там.
>> Притом, насколько помню, в
международном, да, у вас даже был меня
обвиняли там, а в создании
международного преступного сообщества.
Это холдинг, преступный холдинг,
объединяющий много организованных
преступных групп. Да, вы были там
главарём? Да,
>> я там был главарём. То есть даже там я
преуспел. Далее у нас последовал
конфликт с Назарбаевым. Дело в том, что
четыре ведущих банка страны в то время
контролировали 82% рынка. Так вот,
четвёртый банк принадлежал его зятю, а
три банка были независимые. Вот он решил
их забрать.
>> Один из них был ваш?
>> Да. У меня был третий банк в стране.
Начались политические преследования.
Совокупно мне светило более 20 лет
тюрьмы. Там Интерпол, розыск по всем
странам мира и так далее. А, а потом,
когда я всё победил, выиграл и так
далее, соцсети и я опять там, а сейчас
искусственный интеллект, я опять там.
>> То есть и вот друзья мне всё время
говорят: "Почему вот
>> каждый тренд, ты в каждом тренде вот
присутствуешь?"
>> Чтобы подытожить, точка А. Вы в Ауле,
пастух, нулевой стартовый капитал. Точка
Б, ваш пик бизнесовой игры. Почти 6 млрд
- это капитализация всех ваших активов.
А после этого конфликт, значит, серия
политических, да,
>> 7 лет судов,
>> 7 лет судов
>> до шестнадцатого года,
>> насколько я помню, ну, из публичных
оценок ваш капитал потом стал
оцениваться в районе 200 млн долларов.
>> Это после я уже заново начал.
>> Это когда вы уже то есть вы вообще
обнулились?
>> Не, у меня отняли всё.
>> Вообще всё
>> у меня отняли всё: банк, месторождения,
девелоперское компании. У меня было
более 200 компаний. Всё отняли. Вот всё
подчастую. 7 лет я провёл в судах. После
того, как выиграл суд в Дубае, в
Лондоне, в Люксембурге, а в
Лихтенштейне, в Тюрике и в Казахстане.
После этого я очистился. Это 2016 год.
>> Угу.
>> И в шестнадцатом году я заново начал
бизнес.
>> И вот это 200 млн- это уже то, что вы
>> Да, на самом деле не 200, меньше.
Это
там объективно, если смотреть, там в
районе 150 170 млн.
>> А, но
как я даже в одном из интервью говорил,
на самом деле я не преследовал
заработать деньги, потому что я считаю,
ну, для того, чтобы жить жизнью
миллиардера, достаточно иметь 100 млн
>> 100 млн
>> долларов,
>> да,
>> в виде активов или в виде кашло?
>> А, в виде работающих активов. бизнеса.
Ну, чтобы эти 100 млн могли генерить там
12% в годовых.
>> После того, как клан Назарбаевых
ээ ушёл, экак,
ну, нельзя было откатить или
пересмотреть, если вы в судах выиграли,
чтобы вам активы вернули?
>> Я писал заявление во всей инстанции, э,
после ухода Назарбаева. Ну, потому что у
нас была объявлена политика справедливый
Казахстан и так далее. Везде отписки.
Более того, когда я сам начал собирать
документы, многие документы, на основе
которых у меня изъяли активы, были
уничтожены даже в государственных
архивах.Гу.
>> То есть это говорит о том, что работала
преступная группа, которая зачистила
после себя следы. У меня есть все
доказательства. Знаешь, я на самом деле
не сильно это преследую, потому что я
считаю, что с будущего заработать
гораздо легче, чем с прошлого. Маргулан,
скажите, а в каком проценте случаев при
запуске ваших бизнесов вы ошибались и не
достигали успеха?
>> Наверное, 95% бизнесов, которые я
инициировал сам,
>> Ага.
>> заканчивались банкротство.
>> С ума сойти. Ничего себе. Я сейчас
>> это я ещё оптимистично говорю.
>> 95%.
>> А и в то же время 90
больше 90% денег я заработал на сделках,
которые мне не просто принесли и мне
навязали.
Я не не ходил в них участвовать.
>> Следуя этой формуле, лучше вас исключить
как можно раньше из стадии принятия
решения.
>> Абсолютно. Абсолютно правильно. Я вообще
считаю, что решение должен принимать не
я, а контекст внешней ситуации.
То есть сделки. А смотри, я как вот
поясню.
Вся моя задача должна быть не в принятии
решений. Я должен строить улей,
куда будут лететь пчёлы с мёдом. какую
среду.
>> Я строю только улье. Это гарантированная
вещь. Я не ищу мёд, я не ищу цветы, я не
работаю как пчела. А поиском мёда и
поиском цветов занимаются люди, у
которых это лучше получается.
>> Это же вопрос такой, что если брать
каждого человека как гипотезу, 10.000
человек занимается бизнесом, у одного
выстреливает, а судьбу 9.999
никто не знает.
Поэтому там шансы минимальные.
Я не хочу этим заниматься.
>> Может ли человек, который видел причины
в каких-то внешних обстоятельствах,
потому что его так среда воспитала, ну
вот у него там окружение такое было, я
не знаю, родители, одноклассники,
коллеги, всегда же удобно сказать, что
виноват там государство: "А вот тебе
повезло, а вот у того родители, а у меня
образование было не такое, как у них,
конечно, они приехали". То есть всегда
можно найти причины. Вот может ли
человек с таким майндсетом, с такими
установками врождёнными и
сформировавшими его за 20-30 лет, может
ли он потом поменять этот подход и
что-то в себе трансформировать и
попробовать по-другому? Вот посмотрев
там, например, наш подкаст, либо человек
уже сформированный, ему очень сложно
будет вот так вот а переосознать взгляд
на мир.
>> А, ну у меня подход такой, что я
верю, что, ну, во-первых, я верю и вижу,
что мир динамичен, нет ничего
статичного, всё двигается.
Соответственно, почему бы человеку не
быть динамичным? Соответственно, если мы
за год меняем все клетки,
по сути, через год от прошлогоднего
Дениса уже ничего нет, да, это новый
Денис. А то почему
наш менталитет и характер не должен
измениться? Они могут измениться до
определённой степени, но измениться
могут. Вопрос, что будет триггером?
Различные обстоятельства бывают
триггером. Бывает так, что человек уже
до самого дна скатился и понимает, что
всё, так жить нельзя. И вот тогда, в
таких ситуациях, только тогда, когда
жизнь конкретно бьёт его по лицу на
отмошь, только в этот момент человек
может начать меняться. Такого, что там я
сидел на диване и вдруг: "А ну-ка,
дай-ка я изменюсь". Нет, такого не
происходит никогда.
>> Только через боль.
>> Только через боль. Только через боль.
Ну, это закон жизни, потому что а
человек привык, он живёт в своей
привычной среде, ему так комфортно, он в
зоне комфорта, его его должен кто-то
выпнуть из этой зоны комфорта. и тогда
он поймёт, что надо что-то с этим
делать.
>> А эта небольшая пауза нужна для того,
чтобы вы успели подписаться на мой
Telegram-канал. Сколько бы мы себя не
прокачивали в теме soft [музыка] skills,
без hard skills никуда. В своём канале я
пишу именно об этом, как [музыка] на
практике каждый день строю свой бизнес,
что мне помогает оставаться на плаву и
развиваться даже в это непростое
турбулентное время. Как не терять
актуальность, [музыка] как добиваться
результатов и делать так, чтобы твоя
жизнь и жизнь твоих близких была в
порядке? Переходите по ссылке в
описании, и я вас [музыка] там очень
жду. А мы продолжаем. Какой вопрос в
этом году вы чаще всего себе задавали?
>> Достаточно ли далеково я смотрю?
А учитываю ли я все факторы? Но в целом,
если брать, это больше про калибровку
своей адекватности.
Поясните. А,
>> ну дело в том, что когда мир ускоряется
и усложняется, основная проблема в том,
что вот смотрите, есть реальность, а
есть ваше представление об этой
реальности. Когда они не совпадают, вы
попадаете в кризис,
>> да, в неоправданные ожидания. Да, это не
только неоправданное ожидания, это и
несбывшиеся надежды, и так далее.
Поэтому, если самое главное, вы
адекватно выстраиваете мнение о самом
себе, а это и есть эго, эго - это
представление человека от самом себе,
>> Угу.
>> то вы более точно будете понимать этот
мир, и вы будете эффективный. Поэтому во
времена быстрых изменений чаще
задумываться о своей адекватности.
>> А как вам кажется, какие личные качества
предпринимателя
помогают ему не заблудиться?
>> Первое - это умение управлять своим эко.
Все успешные люди, если посмотришь, они
с точки зрения своего эго очень скромны.
Все по-настоящему умные люди, они всегда
сомневаются. Это только дураки не
сомневаются. Они железно уверены в том,
что говорят. Ну вот даже простой пример,
как работает эго против нас. Например,
эго - это завышенное самомнение у нас
самих, на наше представление у нас
самих. Соответственно, когда у нас
завышенное представление о нас самих,
мы, а, выстраиваем неправильное ожидания
в отношении этого мира. всем предъявляем
претензий. И вот когда этот мир не
отвечает на наши ожидания, мы либо
обижаемся, либо разочаровываемся. Так
вот, разочарование и обиды приводят к
чему? Приводит к агрессии. Ты начинаешь
мстить, ты начинаешь ломать, ты
начинаешь давить, ты начинаешь просить,
ты начинаешь требовать. А это всё
признаки слабости. Это показывает, что
ты нуждаешься в этом. Этим миром правит
сила. Люди убегают от всего, что слабое,
и бегут к тому, что всё сильное. А сила
- это когда ты не нуждаешься, когда ты
не предъявляешь, когда ты живёшь свою
жизнью, когда ты довольствуешься малым,
довольствуешься тем, что есть. И вот,
соответственно, когда ты начинаешь это
предъявлять, от тебя люди шарохаются, ты
отпугаешь всех людей. А люди - это
источники возможностей. Все возможности
приходят только через людей. Ты сам
отпугиваешь возможности, соответственно,
ты становишься неудачником. Вот так эго
работает против тебя. А какое ваше
решение вы считаете самым важным или
правильным или максимально эффективным,
который вы приняли за последние годы? За
последний год я принял одно важное
решение, что а мне в этом году уже 59
исполнилось, и я такой как а
изменение стиля, можно сказать, или
опять приведение в соответствие
своей инвестиционной политики, своего
поведения, я сказал, что я не инвестирую
больше в надежды, в желания, в мнение, в
моду и так далее. То есть, что такое? не
инвестировал в надежды, в желания, да,
или, можно сказать, не полагаясь на это,
потому что любой стартап, любой стартап
в любой сфере, любое начинание, это всё
надежды, это всё желание.
А я сейчас перешёл на, э, во-первых, две
вещи. Первое, я полностью перешёл на, а,
сделки.
Это то, на чём я заработал больше 90%,
наверное, своего капитала.
Сделка. Зделка - это, как правило,
инвестирование в специальных ситуациях,
когда там конфликты акционеров, когда
там аа кассовые разрывы, нужно там, ну,
всегда какая-то кризисная ситуация.
>> У,
>> это первый момент. А второй момент э я
отошёл от э
концепции инвестируй и молись.
Ну, то есть в моём мире сейчас всё так
построено, так что право на мои деньги
компания должна заслужить.
>> Угу. А для этого я формирую, что бы я не
говорил, что бы не делал, что бы я не
утверждал, что бы не решал и куда бы я
не инвестировал, я сначала это оформляю
как гипотезу, потом проверяю на данных и
есть ли это, э, компания либо моё
решение доказывает право на жизни, после
этого масштабирую.
>> Угу. Я правильно понимаю, значит, э вы
перестали вкладывать и инвестировать в
проекты на ранних стадиях, где очень
высокая доля венчура. стадиях, не только
на ранних стадиях, вообще в любые
компании, знаешь, обычно как, а все
компании, когда делают презентации, они
приходят и рисуют вот такие графики.
Вот,
>> вот точка, где ты проинвестировал, и
после тебя. Я всё время им говорил и
смеялся, говорю: "Почему клюшка
начинается после меня, а не до меня?
Давайте сделаем чуть-чуть сначала
клюшка, а потом я".
>> А зачем тогда вы, если уже клюшка уже
есть? Зачем тогда мне инвесторы?
>> Да. И вот вопрос
какой?
Что я говорю? Вот эти все клюшки, потом
вот эти разделения Total Accessible
Market, там сам там сам сон и так далее.
Ты говорю, всё, на самом деле, это же
всё надежда, это всё желание,
>> это попытка выдать желаемое за
действительное. Когда вот мы возьмём
сейчас деньги в маркетинг, польём и мы
полетим вот так вот прогноз,
>> да,
>> я всё это режу до текущего момента. Вот
до текущего момента данные покажите мне.
инвестирую только небольшую сумму, чтобы
получить возможность участвовать в
бордее и получать отчётность.
>> Угу.
>> И проверяю гипотезу, что компания, да,
способна поддерживать такие темпы роста
и так далее, что у неё отчётность
нормальная, что основатель хороший и так
далее. После того, как я собираю все
данные и убеждаюсь в том, что всё
действительно соответствует
действительности, после этого принимаю
решение масштабировать
>> либо списочбы.
Ну, масштабирует именно докупать. Угу.
Ну, то есть условно, вы покупаете некий
входной билет в компанию, оцениваете
безотносительно там роста фаундеров,
плов тот фаундер, который не ставит
амбициозной задачей. И более того,
большинство людей как бы искренне в это
верят. И даже если что-то не получается,
это, ну, это не мошенничество, некие
заблуждения, которые очаруют
предпринимателей и не движимое
становится возраста. Это не я не говорю,
что это плохой метод инвестировать в
надежды молодых людей. Нет,
>> я просто у меня подошёл возраст, когда
уже
>> а как в народе говорят, надежды юношей
питают. Но я осознал, что я уже не
юноша. Соответственно, для себя, я для
себя решил,
>> что я больше надеждами и желаниями не
питаюсь.
>> Да. Вы много времени проводите с
предпринимателями,
а в том числе с теми, которые имеют
возможность платить большие деньги для
того, чтобы двигаться вместе с вами по
жизни. А как бы вы сформулировали
основные ошибки либо слепые зоны людей,
которые к вам приходят и работа с
которыми даёт самый быстрый результат
либо наиболее эффективный?
Что общего? Есть ли вообще общее
>> основа? Смотрите, основа такая. А я
вообще
пытаюсь оптимизировать все процессы или
повысить эффективность любого человека.
Работать через узкие горлышки. Это один
из методов моих.
И первым узким горлышком человека,
любого человека, это является энергия,
то, как он ей управляет. А дело в том,
что я видел много успешных людей. Не все
они были умными, но все они были
энергичными. То есть энергия - это самый
главный ресурс, который делает человека
успешным, потому что энергичный человек
просто тупо даже пробует больше,
общается, больше встречается с большим
количеством людей, у него площадь
соприкосновения с реальностью больше.
Соответственно, у него и шансов больше.
И, соответственно, так как у него много
энергии, он позитивен. Первое узкого -
это люди энергичные. Я просто знаю, что
если человек не может управлять своей
энергией, если она ему не дана от
природы, да, то это узко горышко. А
бывает другая ситуация. Человек очень
энергичен, но не может управлять
энергией, не направляет её туда, куда
надо. То есть проблема у неэнергичных
людей управлять энергией, а у энергичных
людей управлять фокусоксом.
>> Угу.
>> Вот это две проблемы. Следующее узкое
горлышко - это эффективность мышления.
Это четыре главных вопроса, над которыми
бились все философы мира, все мудрецы
мира, все религии мира. Я сам их выявил.
Это первый вопрос: каков этот мир?
Второй вопрос: кто я? Третий вопрос:
каково моё место в этом мире? И
четвёртый вопрос: что я действительно
хочу? Человек, пока не ответит на четыре
глобальных этих вопроса, всё, что он
будет делать, это будет в его жизни
хаос, хаотичные движения. Как
предпринимателю выстраивает стратегию,
когда кажется горизонт планирования это
там даже не годы и не месяц зачастую?
>> А, ну вообще нужно сначала чётко понять,
что такое стратегия.
А большинство людей считает, что
стратегия - это план. Это не про план,
не про результаты. Это линия наиболее
эффективного поведения. Так вот, какова
самая правильная, эффективная линия
поведения в нынешних условиях? Вот
представьте, что вы едете и вдруг
воткнулись в туман. Ну вот на машине
туман и ночь. Ну, максимальная плохая
видимость, да? Что вы в это время
делаете? Вы замедляетесь. Второе, вы
переходите на ближний свет. И третье, вы
на ощупь едете. Или вот когда по болоту
идёте, вы же ногой сначала щупаете, как
только на щупали твёрдоя, переносите
вес, дальше ногой щупаете. Или в темноте
идёте, вы руку выставляете вперёд и
идёте щупате. Вот то же самое в нынешних
условиях нужно что делать? Во-первых,
неправильный подход считать, что надо
совершать как можно больше ошибок. И
главное из них извлекать уроки. Это
неправильный подход, потому что, а,
правильный подход совершать как можно
больше маленьких ошибок. Потому что если
ты будешь совершать как можно больше
ошибок и среди них окажется одна-две
большие, то тебе конец. Поэтому
совершать нужно как можно больше
маленьких ошибок, извлекать из них со
всех ошибок уроки и дальше, а, там, где
не ошибка, усиляй сильное. Таким
образом, надо тестировать как можно
больше гипотез. Надо перестать что-либо
утверждать, решать или делать до тех
пор, пока ты не удостоверился, что это
твёрдая почва. Поэтому всё, что вы
хотите решить, либо утверждать или
делать, назвайте это гипотезой. А когда
вы это называете гипотезой, это значит,
нужно определить метрики, через что вы
измеряете успешность, неуспешность
гипотезы. Вы определяете временной срок,
вы определяете бюджет, вы определяете
дальше реакцию. Всё. Поэтому не
пытайтесь умничать в современном мире не
надо пытаться умничать. Не надо
полагаться на свой опыт, знания,
образование, корочку, диплом и так
далее. Надо тестировать гипотезы,
выявлять то, что работает, а дальше
только у себя сильное. Все ресурсы и
внимание направляют в то, что работает.
>> Мы сегодня про взлёты и падение уже
немножко затрагивали тему и поговорим
ещё про это. Мне кажется, вообще один из
таких ярчайших примеров. Вот как
прокатиться на американских горках,
[смех] быть несколько раз внизу на дне.
Оттуда моих американских горок - это
сумасшедшее. Да.
>> Да. И я хотел сделать подарок вам. Мы у
нас не только подкаст на Ютубе, точнее,
у нас уже несколько YouTubeканалов, у
нас уже есть своё бизнес-сообщество, мы
проводим большие конференции. И с этого
года мы стали издавать печатный журнал,
он тоже называется "Основатели". И тема
второго номера как раз-таки называется
взлёты и падения, где мы раскрываем
вообще на примере реальных основателей
эз бизнеса, притом не только из России,
но из э глобальных примеров, из каких-то
исторических ретроспектив, о том, что не
бывает взлётовых без падений и ошибки
это неотъемлемая часть, к сожалению,
любого пути, любого успешного человека.
Вопрос только, делаешь ли ты на основе
этого как какие-то работы над ошибками,
либо ты просто продолжишь опираться.
Поэтому хотел вам подарить журнал.
Магическим образом у меня журнал
оказывается в руках. Я хотел вам
подарить этот журнал.
>> Угу. Спасибо.
>> И ээ пригласить вас в один из следующих
номеров. Мы выходим три раза в год.
>> Угу.
>> И в в следующем году пригласить вас с
одним из героев, либо мы сделаем из
этого материала какой-то спеciл, потому
что не всё попадёт, к сожалению. Мы в
этой части тоже ограничим форматом.
>> Угу.
>> Друзья, снимаем мы несколько часов. Вот,
к сожалению, в эфир попадёт часа
полтора, поэтому мы пока не знаем, но
подумаем. Может быть, в следующем номере
сделаем дополнение из невошедшего для
того, чтобы вы мудростью поделились не
только в таком формате видео, но и
впечатке. А это всё-таки другой формат
коммуникации, другая скорость
воспринятия материала. Это это очень
интересно. Бумага - это новая роскошь.
Дада. Согласен. Согласен. Друзья, журнал
можно приобрести, мы не только его дарим
нашим гостям. Каждый желающий может
перейти по ссылке в описании и через
Озон купить последний номер основателя.
Их осталось не так много. Мы уже готовим
новый номер, поэтому спешите. Журналы
пока ещё есть. Я рассказал вам про еду.
Это вот аналог профе.руru в Егорруди.
>> Угу. А мы, когда делали еду в самые
первые годы, а мы решили происследовать,
что отличает тех исполнителей, которые
мало зарабатывают и получает плохие
оценки. А после каждого задания заказчик
всегда пишет оценку, и исполнитель тоже
ставит оценку и пишет отзыв на
заказчика. И что объединяет тех, кто
получает классные оценки, а как
следствие более высокий заработок. А
наняли двух классных специалистов,
социологов, они провели исследования.
Смотрю заключение и, а, первый пункт, а,
незнакомый для меня термин локус
контроля.
>> Угу.
>> Внутренний локус контроля, что вот у
людей, которые успешны, у них внутренний
лос контроля, а у людей, которые
получают плохие отзывы, неуспешны,
внешний. Я начал исследовать, что такое
внутренние и внешние локонтроли. И для
меня открылся целый огромный мир,
который потом подтверждался огромное
количество раз в беседах с
предпринимателей. Притом об этом пишет и
условный Рейдалио. о том, что
большинству выдающихся людей успешных
всегда свойственен внутренний локус
контроля. И какой-нибудь там Тони Робинс
тот же в своих книгах, то есть два
человека абсолютно разные по принципам,
но они пишут про одно и то же, что если
человек видит причины в себе прежде
всего и своих успехов, и неудач, и
пытается как-то на основе этого что-то
поменять, то он всегда выбивается
статистически выше. Если человек всегда
видит объективные причины, почему не
получилось, а они всегда есть, ты всегда
их найдёшь, то ты, скорее всего, там
останешься.
>> Смотри, у успешных людей есть два важных
момента. Первое, успешные люди, и это,
кстати, в исламе идеально об этом
говорится, успешные люди всегда, во всех
неудачах и проблемах винят только себя.
А в исламе говорится, во всех ваших
проблемах и бедах виноваты вы сами. А
все свои удачи, достижения и результаты
успешные люди приписывают везению, э,
команде, партнёрам, другим людям. Они
очень благодарны в этом плане. А в
исламе говорится: "Все ваши проблемы и
беды от вас, а всё благо от Всевышнего.
>> Всевышнего.
>> Вот формула успеха". Вот. А что делают
бедные люди, а наоборот, когда у них
что-то получается, что они говорят? Они
бьют себя в грудь и говорят: "Это я, это
я, это я сделал". Соответственно, у них
нет благодарности, соответственно, никто
с ними не хочет работать. А когда что-то
у них не получается, они, о, это виноват
тот, виноват тот, они всё время ищут
крайне.
>> И вот видите,
>> какая огромная разница даже в простом
психологическом восприятии, механизме. А
это как раз один из таких принципов. Вот
это яркий показатель, пример, вот эти
принципы, которые я вычленяю из жизни. и
собираю то, что работает, что нет, что
работает, что нет.
>> Мы с вами почти все конструкции
ментальные, которые сегодня разбираем,
они все основаны на каких-то мягких
навыках, да? Они все про нашу
ментальность, целеполагание,
восприятие мира, отношения к нему. А
какие бы так называемые skills вы бы
порекомендовали предпринимателям,
а на которых они должны сфокусироваться
в ближайшее время для того, чтобы вот
эту эпоху неопределённости и ускорения
пройти с максимальной выгодой для себя?
>> Ну а хардскилы на самом деле, а смотри,
не только хардскилы или софтскилы - это
а не это важно. У меня даже отдельная
лекция есть, которая называется о вреде
лишних знаний. Знания тоже нужно
приобретать только для определённой
цели. Не надо становиться кладбищем
ненужных знаний. Нужно приобретать
знания в зависимости от необходимости
решать ту или иную проблему. А та или
иная проблема возникает только тогда,
когда ты ставишь ту или иную цель.
Поэтому прежде всего определитесь со
своими целями. Как только вы начнёте
действовать, вы начнёте сталкиваться с
проблемами. Как только вы начнёте
сталкиваться с проблемами, возникнет
потребность в знании того, как решить
эту проблему. Всё, приобретайте знания,
меняйте своё поведение. И менять надо не
софт скилы и не хард скилы, а менять
надо именно те скилы, которые решают эту
проблему. Как китайцы говорят, неважно,
какого цвета кошка, лишь бы она мышей
ловила. Я к знаниям отношусь точно так
же. Для меня деление на софт скилы,
хардскилы бессмысленно. Для меня
значение имеет только одно: знание
решает проблему или нет. не решает всё,
можно и забыть.
>> Может быть, какие-то общие есть,
например, промнжениринг, который как
будто бы в любом случае тебе будет
полезен. Неважно, какая у тебя цель
стоит и какие знания ты хочешь получать.
Просто полезно общаться с с
искусственным интеллектом максимально
эффективно.
>> А нет, промнжениринг тоже важно в
зависимости от целей. Промтненеринг -
это как молоток. Что ты делаешь важнее
самого инструмента? Смотри, те же орехи
ты можешь колоть и плоскогубцами, и
кирпичом, и молотком.
А, да, даже можно кулаком.
>> Ну да.
>> Поэтому промтоинженеринг - это один из
инструментов. Также
>> инструмент должен быть самосбен цели,
которую ты.
>> Ну, как бы хорошо, когда у тебя есть
понимание, какие инструменты вообще в
принципе можно использовать.
Это и молоток, и плоскогубцы, и там
открывашка, и нож, и там кирпич, и так
далее. Но что использовать зависит от
эффективности, от момента, от контекста.
Вот смотри. А у меня есть такоя, а,
концепция силы. И вот я там тоже
преподаю такой момент. Смотрите, говорю,
сила кажется нам, простым людям, вроде
абсолютной истиной, да? Сила она и есть
сила. Но на самом деле сила зависит от
контекста.
А что такое от контекста? От от сила
зависит от того, как ты используешь вот
эти четыре вопроса. Каков этот мир? Кто
ты? Каково твоё место и каковы твои
цели? Приведу простой пример. Если ты
бывал на природе, может, видел, нет,
когда орёл летает на низких высотах, его
долбят все, кому не лень. И сороки, и
вороны, и воробьи.
>> Нет.
>> Почему? Потому что на низких высотах
орёл теряет все свои преимущества. Это
тот же самый орёл с теми же самыми
большими крыльями, но он беспомощный в
лесу. Его зоркое зрение в лесу не нужно.
Его большие крылья, которые нужны для
ловли потоков воздуха, становятся его
тяжестью. Потому что махать ими очень
тяжело. Но стоит ему подняться на
высоту, он обретает силу. Его зоркий
глаз нужен для того, чтобы осматривать
огромный огромные просторы и находить
добычу. Высота быстро конвертируется в
скорость, а скорость увеличивает его
массу. Если у него масса 5-6 кг, то на
скорости она может быть 500-600 кг.
Соответственно, он может валить добычу
больше, чем он сам весом.
Соответственно, силу-то получается ему
даёт его местоположение,
а не его мышцы. Заметьте, когда он
правильно отвечает на вопрос: "Каков
этот мир и каково моё место в этом мире
и кто я, он обретает силу. А как только
меняет положение, всё, он никто". И в
жизни тоже самое.
>> Является ли бизнесовый результат,
который выражается в очень простой
метрике? это деньги, цифры, аа
некой метрикой исследовательской. То
есть можно ли исследовать мир и при этом
говорить, что я его классно исследовал,
потому что результат на табло там
миллиард долларов.
>> А, конечно, смотри, деньги - это один из
видов ресурсов. А на самом деле в этом
мире самый главный ресурс - это энергия.
А и вообще всё, весь наш мир - это
сплошное энергетическое поле. Это
постоянное движение, динамика,
трансформации энергии из одного вида в
другой. Всё, что происходит - это
движется энергия. Даже твёрдые предметы,
которые мы сейчас считаем твёрдыми -
это, на самом деле, энергия притяжения
квантовых частиц друг к другу. Вот и
всё. А поэтому, а, в этом мире всё
энергия. Деньги - энергия, власть -
энергия, слава - это энергия, а
репутация - это энергия, а почёт,
уважения - это тоже энергия. связи - это
тоже энергия. Я это всё обозначаю как
ресурсы. И вот моё понятие, понимание,
что такое ресурсы. Ресурсы - это
законсервированная, взаимообмениваемая
энергия. Вот что такое ресурсы. Почему
законсервированная? Потому что, чтобы
получить деньги, власть, славу,
репутацию, почёт, уважения, связи, ты
должен в прошлом был за должен был
затратить энергию, она консервируется,
потом ты можешь этим обмениваться. Ты
можешь власть конвертировать в почёт
уважения. Почёт уважения можешь
конвертировать в деньги, деньги можешь
конвертировать в славу. И эти ресурсы
обмениваются.
>> Угу.
>> Поэтому деньги - это как одна из метрик.
Одна из метрик. И я бы сказал, не самое
главное. Поэтому она хороший показатель,
да. А когда ты играешь на бизнес-поле,
есть определённые правила игры, и там
счёт ведётся в деньгах.
>> Например, во власти. Это тоже другой вид
игры, но там счёт ведётся во влиянии.
А, например, э в Славе, когда ты
преследуешь славу, это другой вид игры.
Там счёт ведётся на уровень известности
и доверия, то есть репутация. Таким
образом, в каждой игре есть свои метрики
счёта.
>> Вы в каждой игре играете?
>> А, практически, да, я играю в каждой
игре. Аа м почему? Потому что,
опять-таки, это позволяет мне изучать
этот мир и а это показывает мне, что
если законы, которые я выявил, они
действующие и правильные, то они
действуют в любых сферах. Угу.
>> Независимо это семейные отношения, а
бизнес, политика, экономика, спорт и так
далее.
>> Были ли какие-то решения в этом году,
которые дались вам лично тяжелее других?
>> Наверное, нет. Я, во-первых, ээ строю
жизнь таким образом, чтобы не принимать
тяжёлых больших решений.
>> Аа
>> как это возможно в бизнес?
>> Что такое большие тяжёлые решения? Это
не вовремя принятые маленькие решения.
Когда ты не принимаешь вовремя маленькие
тяжёлые решения, они накапливаются и в
конце превращаются в одно большое
решение.
>> Да,
>> это проблема же она не появляется в один
день.
Сначала есть признаки, симптомы, которые
появляются, ты не реагируешь, они
усугубляются те, ты не реагируешь, они
уже в конце кричат, ты не реагируешь. И
когда наступает вот реальная задница,
тогда только ты вынужден принять
большое, тяжёлое решение.
>> Угу.
А если ты, а, любые плохие новости
встречаешь первым и даже приветствуешь
это и не наказываешь людей, которые тебе
приносят плохие новости, это приводит к
тому, что ты реагируешь быстрее на более
ранней стадии и решаешь проблему до
того, как она превращается в большую
страшную проблему.
>> Как бы вы описали
время, в котором мы сейчас находимся с
вами?
А я бы описал время, это
время ускорения.
А потому что я никогда не чувствовал, а
такое нарастание скорости с каждым днём.
Если раньше время у меня и прогресс
воспринимался как-то линейно,
то вот я прямо сейчас остро чувствую вот
эту клюшку.
А как прямо с каждым днём прогресс
ускоряется и время ускоряется. Мы
максимально близко, наверное, уже
приближаемся к точке сингулярности.
А а точка сингулярности - это когда
человек, а уже не в состоянии
отслеживать
прогресс, который происходит. То есть я
сам смотрю очень много каналов,
новостей, всё, что связано с яя роботами
и так далее. И даже при этом еле-еле
поспеваю читать все статьи. настолько
быстро выходит обновление, настолько
быстро выходят новые технологии, новые
какие-то методы, инструменты и так
далее.
>> А как вам кажется, что сейчас важнее аа
с точки зрения приложения
фундаментальных усилий, а скорость
изменений или качество изменений для
предпринимателя?
Какие бы качественные изменения ты не
делал, если ты не будешь делать быстро,
то в сегодняшнем мире, сегодняшний мир
построен таким образом. Смотри, это
раньше была концепция, так? А ты берёшь
и делаешь что-то хорошо,
а сейчас так. Сейчас гораздо выгоднее
делать много-много плохо, но главное
плохо. Потом быстро собрал обратную
связь, исправил. Сделал чуть лучше,
собрал обратную связь, сделал чуть
лучше, собрал обратную связь, сделал
чуть лучше. Сейчас критическое значение
имеет цикл улучшений,
а не изначально плохо и либо хорошо. Ты
можешь начать сначала с какого-нибуд
продукта и очень быстро прийти к
совершенному продукту. А кто-то может в
это время сидеть и пытаться сразу
сделать совершенный продукт. За это
время он профукает весь рынок, всё,
инвесторов, рынок, потребителей.
Поэтому это не вопрос качества, вопрос
скорости сейчас важнее. Поэтому
пытайся делать качественно в рамках тех
временных
возможностей, которые у тебя есть.
>> Вы много времени тратите на попытку
отслеживать изменения вообще, что
происходит. У меня в этой части
абсолютная фома, потому что я, будучи
айтишником, даже я либо боюсь той
скорости, которая происходит, либо даже
я не понимаю. Более того, опираясь на
какие-то исследования, которые я читал
ещё в этом году, где люди, а дают
определённые предсказания и предикции,
что вот через 2 года мы достигнем
качество нашей модели, потом проходят 3
месяца, и они её достигают. Я понимаю,
что даже если люди вовлечённые, которые
непосредственно создают и яй, даже если
они так ошибаются, то что взять с меня
как потребителя, потому что я всё-таки
не создаю, я потребляю и пытаюсь как-то
успевать. Я-то вообще ничего не понимаю.
Нужно просто расслабиться и наблюдать. И
вот есть такой тезис, что ведь в начале
века, прошлого, а не так важно было, кто
первый сел на автомобиль и кто пересел с
повозки на авто. тоже был энтузиазм
огромный, создавались автоклубы. Всё
равно история плюс-минус в течение 10-20
30т 30 лет всех раскидала, и деньги на
автомобильном рынке заработали другие
ребята, не которые там придумали,
поставили двигатель внутреннего сгорания
на на повозку. Есть такой тезис, что
сейчас нужно просто расслабиться, что ИА
это хайп, он огромные деньги потратят
сейчас венчурные фонды, перегреют рынок,
пузырь там лопнет, не лопнет, неважно.
Ну, пройдёт какое-то количество времени,
и туда уже придут более такие понятные
институциональные деньги. Скажут так:
"Что вы тут напридумывали? Ага, всё,
давайте это будем внедрять". Нет ли
ощущения, что мы как бы чуть-чуть вот
этим фома, которая в нас есть, и
попыткой успеть бежим, как будто бы
пытаясь запрыгнуть в последний поезд,
последний вагон поезда, а на самом деле
это не последний вагон,
>> а есть большое отличие вот AI хайпа от а
любых других видов пузырей. А AI - это
реальная технология, которая реально
заменяет труп, реально повышает
эффективность. То есть то, что хайп на
рынке есть, это, безусловно, хайп есть,
и он, безусловно, сдуется. Но вопрос в
том, что эффективность экономики
по-любому поднимется. Искусственный
интеллект делает реальные вещи, он
заменяет реальный труд, и он приносит
добавленную стоимость. Соответственно,
те компании, в которые будут больше
использовать искусственного интеллекта,
а у них будет себестоимость ниже, и они
будут быстрее в обслуживании, они будут
более дружелюбные, они будут легче
масштабироваться, соответственно, они
просто долю вашего рынка сожрут и всё.
Это не вопрос то, что надо расслабиться
здесь. Если ты расслабишься, то
прогресс-то не расслабится. Здесь ещё
ситуация немного другая. И
это не пройдёт мимо, это коснётся всех и
каждого.
Всех и каждого. А когда к искусственному
интеллекту приделают руки и ноги в виде
роботов, то это коснётся 100% людей.
И здесь вопрос меня беспокоит не вопрос
заработка денег. Я считаю, что когда,
ну, я вижу в горизонте 20 лет, вообще
человек отойдёт от создания
экономической
стоимости или ценности.
А всё будут делать роботы и
искусственный интеллект, там, ну, по
крайней мере, очень большую часть
работы. Проблема в том, что чем больше
экономической ценности будут создаваться
роботами и искусственным интеллектом,
тем меньше у человека будет смысла,
смысла жизни, потому что у большинства
людей смыслом жизни является обеспечение
себя. А ещё у другой, ээ, большого
количества
ну, большой части людей смыслом жизни
является сама игра, создание ценности,
конкуренция, достижения, то есть
самореализация, не самообеспечение, а
самореализация.
И это тоже отойдёт. И вопрос, чем люди
займутся? В чём люди теперь будут
находить смысл?
И меня интересует, вот я когда изучаю
искусственный интеллект
и роботов, я, безусловно, знаю, что они
убьют и бизнес, и экономику. Не то, что
убьют, это будет, а, я здесь согласен с
Илом Маскам, наверное, а всеобщий
уровень благостояния. Все будут жить
очень хорошо, потому что роботы могут
производить роботов, могут чинить
роботов и выполнять любую работу. И,
соответственно, необходимость человека
отпадёт. Но вопрос возникает: а что
будет делать человек? А отчасти с тобой
согласен, что надо расслабиться. А, но
расслабиться в каком плане? Не так,
чтобы ничего не делать. Просто понимая,
что теперь будет делать искусственный
интеллект, находить свою уникальность.
Искусственный интеллект будет забирать в
первую очередь всю ту работу, которую
может делать, сделать любой. И только в
последнюю очередь он будет посягать на
то, что можешь сделать только ты.
Поэтому нахождение своей уникальности -
это и будет смысл жизни каждого
человека, и это и будет единственное
конкурентное преимущество человека по
сравнению с искусственным интеллектом.
>> Теперь вопрос от Альфабанка. Что вы
внедрили в своей личной жизни, не в
бизнесе, а либо изменили благодаря
искусственному интеллекту и получили
какой-то результат, либо повысили
эффективность за последнее время,
какой-то пример практически.
>> У меня много, у меня много. Я управление
знаниями прежде всего, а управление
знаниями, система размышлений, аэ я
очень обширно использую. У меня 28
ассистентов я создал на всякий на все
случаи жизни. У меня даже есть ассистент
его зовут Дерсузала.
Это из книги из фильма Дерсузала. А если
смотрели советский фильм, это такой
гольд на Дальнем Востоке охотник. Это
охотник прирождённый. И вот я занимаюсь,
один из моих хоббий - это охота.
Соответственно, я у дерсу за вас
спрашиваю, какую экипировку купить,
какой бинокль выбрать, как выстроить
баллистику патрона, у какого патрона
какая баллистика, как учёт ветра,
прицел, вынос, вот эти все вещи. Я пишу
ему, он всё узнает.
>> На основе чего вы научили его? Аа а дело
в том, что, во-первых, пишется,
во-первых, паспорт - аэ ассистента,
потом полностью его профиль, потом
определяется сфера и источники, на
которую может опираться,
>> да,
>> и после этого уже создаётся как бы аа а
паспорт, профи, его профиль и файлы. Все
файлы я туда загружаю, там
характеристики своего оружия от
существующих биноклей. а-а наша там, ну,
условно локация, он сразу подтягивает
погоду в этой местности, высота над
уровнем моря, а какая дичь там водится,
сезонность, разрушение, а сезон охоты,
вот всём с интернета всё подтягивает. Я
просто, как прописано у него, что это, и
он на основе вот этого всего даёт,
например, я могу спросить, какой патрон
мне использовать в этом сезоне? Он
спрашивает: "Когда выезжаешь на охоту?"
Я говорю: "Такого числа?" Он говорит:
"Смотри, в это время обычно температура
такая-то. Зверь, он поднимается в горы
или, наоборот, спускается с гор, потому
что его снег придавливает, поэтому
высота стрельбы, скорее всего, будет
такая-то, такая-то". Он пасётся обычно
рано утром либо поздно ночью, поэтому
лучше использовать тепловизорный прицел.
Тепловизорный прицел лучше модель такая
такая-то, потому что дальность плюс
встроенный лазерный дальномеры и так
далее. устанавливаешь на карабин
такой-то, патрон такой-то, вес пули
такой-то, баллистика у пули такая-то,
производвная способность такая, и там,
короче, всё, всё. Вот это только частный
случай. А большую часть времени я,
конечно, использую для своих философских
вещей, для исследований, для
размышлений, для выявления законов. Я
тестирую законы этого мира. Я говорю:
"Вот я считаю, вот так вот так будет".
Как ты думаешь, к чему это может
привести? Вот я считаю вот такие
такие-то исходы. Разжи мне вероятность
этих исходов. Он мне рассказывает
вероятность. Я говорю: "Давай вместе
теперь протестируем". Мы начинаем это
тестировать. Я с ним веду как вот с
младшим научным сотрудником, усно
говоря. У меня даже есть совет
директоров,
>> где все участники.
>> Кто в него входит?
>> Туда входит Урен. Это про прообраз
Уорена Бафида.
>> Угу.
>> Туда входит Боби. Боби - это прообраз
Боби ак акселерода. жёсткого бизнесмена
и сери миллиардеры. Миллиарды,
>> да, миллиарды.
>> А туда входит Логос. Это я дал имя, но
это человек, который рассуждает только
строго логически,
ээ, больше никак. Любое нарушение логики
он сразу чувствует.
>> Угу.
>> Туда входит Сократ. Сократ у него
сократический метод, он ищет ответы
всегда задавая вопросы. Всё время он не
даёт своих, э, решений, он всё время
задаёт вопросы. Туда входит Дон Хуан.
Дон Хуан - это из книги Карлса
Кастанеда. Это он отвечает за эзотерику,
потому что не всё в этом мире можно
прочитать логически и объяснять и
объяснить причиноследственной связью,
потому что многие вещи в этом мире,
причина и следствие, разнесены во
времени и пространстве.
И а если мы это не видим, мы не
понимаем, но на уровне эзотерики это
понятно. Поэтому туда входит Дон Хуан,
туда ходит Венди,
это психолог перфон
перформанс психолог. Это психолог,
который заточен на достижение цели. И он
объясняет, она объясняет, почему надо
поступать так и не так. Ну, с учётом, а,
психологии других людей.
>> А вот пятёрка моего совета директоров.
И на различные эти я ещё проблемы создаю
рабочей группой.
>> Угу.
>> И вот когда я своему искусственному
интеллекту что-то пишу, он сразу мне
пишет: "С каким советником ассистентом
ты хочешь работать? Там, на самом деле,
очень важно правильно выстроить
ассистента. Целая работа. А потом к этим
ассистентам ещё вот прибавить агентов.
То есть а важно, чтобы каждый агент имел
свой профиль.
И вот когда ты делаешь рой агентов,
у каждого агента должна быть ещё своя
роль или свой профиль, и он должен
отвечать за какую-то вещь. Если,
например, агент-верификатор,
то он должен быть очень скептически
настроен. Он должен знать все последние
научные достижения в области
критического мышления. Он должен знать
все когнитивные искажения там и так
далее. Ну,
от настройки этого очень много зависит.
Мне, знаете, одно из моих последних
открытий было в Ai, где внедрил свою
жизнь, очень сильно испугался в моменте.
Я больше 15 лет веду дневник в цифровом
виде,
что, на мой взгляд, является самым
лучшим инструментом психоразвития.
Самым лучшим инструментом саморазвития и
психоанализа в том числе. Потому что
какой бы год ты не открыл, ты можешь
посмотреть объективную картинку, кто ты.
>> Угу. Там всё, что 10 плюс лет, я читаю
каждый раз и думаю: "Да я не мог это
написать. Ну это какая-то ерунда. Ну это
бред. Я вообще, ну то есть ты
сталкиваешься сам с собой. Это
объективная картинка. Вот ты был такой,
ты об этом мечтал, ты об этом переживал.
Сейчас тебе кажется, конечно, нет, но
вот на самом деле так ощущение буд тебя
взломали и переписали половину дневника
какие-то какие-то хакеры. Я в этом году
скормил все эти дневники ий
не сразу получилось, потому что в
какой-то момент я и стал дописывать,
исправлять. Ну, в общем, в итоге я
сделал, а, первый подход, и буквально за
несколько сообщений я начал спрашивать
его, а, задавать ему вопросы текущие, и
через несколько сообщений просто
холодный пот, я прямо отпрыгнул от
компьютера, потому что он начал выдавать
такую информацию, которую я уже вообще
забыл. И я начинаю спрашивать, я думаю,
может быть, он сам придумал, почему ты
так это решил. И он начинает находить
взаимосвязи за разные годы и говорит:
"Так вот же у тебя же по повторяется
один и тот же паттерн. Смотри". И в
какую-то тему мы ушли настолько
глубокую, что стало страшно. То есть я
впервые как будто бы познакомился сам с
собой, при том, что до этого у меня был
опыт работа с психотерапевтом и как бы я
вообще очень люблю по покопаться в себе,
пообщаться. И, ну, для меня саморазвитие
- это очень как бы ва важная важная
сфера жизни. Но мне правда стало
страшно. Я потом почти месяц не мог
подойти. То есть я сделал такой крутой
инструмент, и мне было страшно.
Удивительно, я даже когда знакомым
рассказывал, мне говорит: "Блин, как же
здорово, что там 15 лет назад начал
вести дневник". Я говорю: "Смотри, а
большую часть самых полезных советов,
которые получил, он мне дал на основе
последнего года. Угу.
>> Вообще ничего не мешает хотя бы раз в
месяц фиксировать. Даже писать не надо,
просто возьми, начни наговаривать. Очень
простой фреймворк, о чём тебе нужно
сказать. И вот ты увидишь уже за первые
3 месяца накопи хотя бы немного данных.
Дальше буквально там, ну вот вечер нужно
посидеть пару часов и у тебя будет живой
инструмент. И и в этой части это
действительно ну очень легко сделать.
Просто нужны данные.
А, огромный инструмент. Люди
недооценивают просто.
У меня есть, например, а, ну, советники
по человеческим отношениям. Я могу
просто взять твоё одно сообщение,
загрузить туда и и он тебе и он мне
расскажет, а что ты написал, что ты имел
в виду, почему ты это написал, в какой
стадии ты находишься, что ты в этот
момент чувствуешь, что ты от меня
ожидаешь, что ты от меня ожидаешь
услышать и что ты от меня ожидаешь,
чтобы я действовал. Понимаешь, он с
одного сообщения он разложит семь-девять
слоёв.
>> Угу.
>> Но это зависит от того, как ты настроишь
ассистентов.
>> Угу.
>> Потому что, смотри, я в своё время
изучал искусственный интеллект, думал, я
хотел найти его слабости. А у меня есть
такое правило в жизни, что там, где твоя
сила, там твоя слабость. И я думаю, а в
чём слабость искусственного
интеллект-то? Я понял такую вещь, что
искусственный интеллект, он знает всё,
что есть в интернете. Соответственно,
его сила в том, что он знает всё. А я
так понял, так понял такую вещь, что
когда ты знаешь всё обо всём, то
практически ты не знаешь, ты знаешь мало
о чём-то конкретном. Почему? Например,
когда ты знаешь обо всём, предположим,
давай на примере партии, ты знаешь всё
про республиканцев, всё про демократов.
Соответственно, когда я тебе говорю
что-то, ты даёшь мне среднюю температуру
по больнице. Ты мне даёшь то, что
удовлетворяет и демократов, и
республиканцев. Ты понял? Да. Потому что
на любое утверждение в интернете есть
контрутверждение, да?
>> А он же не знает, какое выбрать. И он
даёт среднее,
>> чтобы и этим, и вашим, и нашим. И вот
это недостаток, потому что он знает, на
любое утверждение есть
контурутверждение, и он знает это
контрутверждение, и он не знает, какую
сторону принять, и, а, даёт среднюю
средний ответ, который который
удовлетворяет большинство людей. И я
понял такую вещь, что моя задача
толкнуть и в крайности. Крайности. Для
этого я делаю одного ассистента жёсткого
республиканца, например, а другого
ассистента жёсткого демократа. И задаю
вопрос и говорю: "Как с твоей точки
зрения?" И он начинает с точки зрения
республиканца долбать по тяжёлой. А
потом он же, ну, уже в роли демократа
начинает долбать эту же точку зрения в
пух и прах, понимаешь? Вот так можно
раскачать его. И когда ты его толкаешь в
крайности, он начинает давать тебе
адекватные мнения, уже более точные. И
когда ты собираешь несколько крайних
точек зрения, ты сам формируешь среднее.
И вот это вот как я определил его
слабости и определил, э как можно его
использовать, его слабости и становиться
ещё сильнее.
>> Можете дать тогда три хайлайта, что на
ваш взгляд искусственный интеллект
никогда не заменит и эта работа
останется для человека? и что
искусственный интеллект должен в
ближайшее время заменить так, что это
убьёт целые рынки профессии либо
отрасли? Ну, смотри, искусственный
интеллект должен, а, может и должен
убрать все рутинные операции, все
скучные рутинные операции, которые не
имеют смысла с точки зрения человека.
Ну, на конвейере передвигать с точки А в
точку Б там или там рисовать дизайн
какого-то сайта. Ну, такие настолько
рутины, банальные операции. Второе,
искусственный интеллект должен
однозначно заменить человека там, где
человек высока вероятность человеческой
ошибки. То есть человек не может
проанализировать одномоментно там 10
стратегий, не может проанализировать там
10.000 сайтов одновременно, не может
прочитать там 15.000 статей. Ну не мо
жизни у него не хватит, а искусственный
интеллект может. То есть там, где у
человека есть узкое горлышко в виде
энергии, времени, внимания,
искусственный интеллект должен это
забрать на себя.
>> Если предположить, что есть какой-то
среднестатистический предприниматель,
который занимается там в сегменте
малого, среднего бизнеса, услугами,
торговлей, неважно. Ну, то есть, ну,
>> пельменная, например,
>> да? А вот что ему сейчас уже нужно
делать,
чтобы подготовиться к эпохе, когда
искусственный интеллект, возможно, в
лучшем случае повлияет на его бизнес, в
худшем случае станет угрозой для его
бизнеса. Если сейчас ещё каких-то
индикаторов о том, что для моей
пельменной искусственный интеллект может
навредить, абсолютно никаких нет. Ну
пусть там что-то все те программисты
делают. Меня люди как приходили пельмени
как ели, так и будут есть. Зачем мне
сейчас тратить время на это?
А, но он сейчас уже может
снижать свою себестоимость, а, и при
этом повышать лояльность клиентов.
Элементарно сделай кол-центр на основе
искусственный интеллект. Не надо
содержать людей. Это хорошо. У тебя
сейчас нет кол-центра, ты маленькая
пельменная. А тут появится кол-центр,
ну, который полностью искусственном теле
отвечает. Причём по всем каналам связи,
хоть WhatsApp, хоть Telegram, хоть
голосом. Это же хорошо твоём бизнес.
Хорошо. Себесоимость растёт, не растёт,
лояльность растёт,
лояльность растёт. Продажи
тоже ты можешь полностью передать
искусственному интеллекту. Маркетинг
передать искусственному интеллекту.
Введение соцсетей, бренда передай
искусственному интеллекту. То есть ты
уже можешь очень много операций передать
искусственному интеллекту, не создавая
новые штаты, не не беря на борт новых
людей, не тратя на на зарплату и так
далее. То есть та же самая пельменная,
просто она не становится больше, но у
тебя клиентов становится больше, они
становятся более лояльные, а у тебя
загрузка пельменной возрастает,
соответственно, себестоимость падает,
соответственно, ты легче
масштабируешься, потому что в любом
месте, куда ты откроешь, там тебя уже
знает.
>> Есть себестоимость внедрения
искусственного интеллекта. И часто,
особенно в малом бизнесе, она абсолютно
нецелесообразна, но просто тебе для
того, чтобы внедрить полноценный AI в
продаже, либо внедрить систему, которая
полностью заменит там первую, вторую
линию кол-центра, а либо ты внедришь
какую-то LLM-модель, которая будет
обучена на твоих данных, это огромные
деньги. И более того, ты сам это не
сделаешь. Скорее всего, тебе потребуется
какой-то интегратор, который это будет
внедрять. То есть насколько
целесообразно вот для пельмены, для
маленькой, которые работают на внешнем
трафина уже прошли, Денис. Эти времена
уже прошли. А колцентр можно создать
одному человеку за неделю.
А причём этот кол-центр будет и
прекрасно отвечать на все вопросы. А
просто берётся лмка, берётся чатбот,
берётся раг
этот
generation, то есть это память,
прикручивается память к ЛМК. Память она,
в свою очередь бывает там векторная база
данных, реализационная база данных или
графовая база данных. То есть она
смысловая, контекстная, любой вид
поиска. Всё, когда приходит запрос через
Telegram либо WhatsApp и так далее,
агенты в том же, например, N8N, он сразу
даёт запрос враг, вытаскивает нужную
информацию, тут же через другого агента
озвучивает голосом и приятным голосом
отвечает на любой вопрос. Это делатся,
ну, блин, недели я вообще взял много.
Я могу создать за 3 дня,
>> но при этом вы несколько лет изучаете
предметно.
>> Нет, сейчас этого добра, тьма на рынке.
Сейчас, ну, блин, студент это может
сделать.
>> Ну, то есть мне не нужно нанимать
специального директора по мартингу,
который мне эту историю. Сейчас уже
столько отработано workflow, столько
отработанных скриптов уже готовых. Ты
можешь на репозитарии, на GitHub зайти,
просто чужое это всё взять и название
всё поменять, вставить и всё.
Люди уже это сделали. Просто возьми
пельмену вместо там кафе на везде встав
название свои пельмены и всё, он уже
работающий колл-центр у тебя.
>> Да. Мне мне мне хочется провести опрос.
Кто из наших пользователей какой процент
примерно знает, что такое гитха?
>> Про вот проблема в том, что люди же не
изучают, а вот надо изучать хотя бы вот
эти вещи. Но это же совсем банальные
вещи.
>> Вот. Да. Давайте дадим а рекомендации
либо какие-то направления. Вот что мне
сейчас нужно начать делать, хотя бы вот,
чтобы с с терминологией познакомиться
или какие-то конференции или какие-то
подкасты, где там best practice ээ
просто насматриваться на это. Угу.
>> Или или пока вот пока мой мой конкурент
соседней пельменной не сделал всё то же
самое, я просто спокойненько сижу, тут у
меня рынок защищён, никаких ээ
конкурентов нету. И я спокойненько, пока
люди приходят, едят и
>> смотри, здесь вопрос в том, что а AI он
не делает людей умнее, он умных делает
умнее, тупых делает тупее. И вопрос вот
в чём: а ты выбираешь развитие или
стагнацию? Если ты выбираешь развитие,
то ты должен всё время решать те задачи,
которые ты не решал до этого. То есть
это значит не те задачи, решения которых
ты знаешь, а нужно заниматься теми
задачами, решения которых ты даже не
знаешь и не представляешь.
Соответственно, а что это значит? Это
значит, ты должен сказать: "Так, да,
искусственный интеллект это всё это
может. Моя задача, вот у меня нет
кол-центров пельменно, сделать
кол-центр. Всё, упирайся. В Ютубе
миллион видео про создание кол-центра. В
Ютбе миллион видео, как это сделать
руками, не подключая никого, никого из
специалистов, выделяя каждый день 2 часа
времени, через неделю ты это сможешь
делать".
Это вопрос выбора человека: расти или не
расти.
Это не так, что там, ой, это сложно, я
не смогу делать это, пускай другие
делают. Это прошло время, когда
программисты были элитой,
интеллектуальной элиты в сознании людей.
И это считало, что люди, которые
разговаривают на инопланетном языке, и
они только пишут для нас приложение, а
потом нам выдают на наша задача только
пользоваться. Сегодня любой человек
может заменить программиста. Любой
человек. какой-то пример за последнее
время, который вас очень сильно удивил
там в вашем бизнесе либо в другом
бизнесе, когда компания внедрила AI и
получила какой-то невероятный результат
и выиграла в скорости или в
эффективности. Что первое приходит,
какой пример на ум?
>> Ну, смотри, ещё таких крупных примеров
нету.
А вообще последние исследования, которые
я считал, 95% крупных компаний не
ощутили эффекта от
интеллекта. Да, они потеряли деньги,
хотя бы проинвестировали миллиарды.
>> Но это вполне закономерно. Это вполне
закономерно. Хайп на искусственный
интеллект выражается выражается ещё в
том, что не только покупает дорого акции
AI компании, но ещё тратит слишком
неразумные деньги на внедрение
искусственного интеллект.
Не надо так делать. Искусственный
интеллект не надо пытаться деньгами
залить. Это обычно как в крупных
корпорациях. Назначается вице-президент
по искусственному интеллекту. Ему
говорят: "Так, в следующем году 15%
наших операций должны выполняться
интеллектом, потом 30%, потом 45 и вот
график".
Это чисто бюрократическая машина, так не
работает. Я ожидаю, что вот в горизонте
3-5 лет мы только почувствуем. С чего бы
вы начали свой путь предпринимателю в
двадцать шестом году, если бы у вас
ничего не было? И вообще пошли бы вы в
предпринимательство в двадцать шестом
году? Ну, смотри, в двадцать шестом
году, а, ну, я бы пошёл, ходил бы в
предпринимательство до тех пор, пока это
самый, ну, условно говоря, для меня
наиболее лёгкий способ зарабатыва денег.
Ну, а я плохо вижу, как я могу
заработать деньги, будучи наёмным. Ну, я
имею в виду, понимаю, но вот деньги там
маленькие, да?
А не вижу, как это делать с политикой,
кроме как взятки. Не хочу брать взяток.
Да. А вот предпринимательство, я чётко
понимаю, это правила игры, как
действовать и так далее. Но для
инвестиций, ты говоришь, ресурсов нет.
О'кей, но можно управлять чужими
деньгами, поэтому можно инвестициями
заниматься тоже. Вообще в целом, если
брать подход, у меня он парадоксальный,
многие удивляются, он такой: если хочешь
добиться успеха в любой сфере, отдавай
много и сразу получай постепенно и
помаленьку. Приведу пример. Я много
работаю с волонтёрами. Так вот, э,
представь, вот волонтёр, я сижу,
волонтёр, э, ходит там, убирает столы на
каком-то форуме, подходит ко мне,
говорит: "Магвич, я вижу, вы отчёт
читаете, давайте я вам настрою Excel,
Power BI". Я говорю: "А что ты можешь?"
Да могу. Он настроил,
всё классно работает. Я такой: "Нифига
себе, а ты откуда знаешь?" Он говорит:
"Да я могу и почту настроить, могу и вам
Telegramбота сделать". Да ты что? Да
сделай. Он раз-раз делает, потом это
делает, потом это. Потом я такое
чувствую, что, блин,
не хочется терять такого человека-то. Я
ему говорю: "Слушай, может ты ко мне на
работу придёшь, на зарплату, я тебе буду
платить?" Он говорит: "Ну, как сами
хотите, я же и так у вас готов было
просто работать". Я начинаю ему платить
зарплату, а он начинает ещё больше
вкладываться, ещё больше работать, ещё
больше ёт. Я чувствую, что он очень
крутой, и я начинаю ему предлагать
повышенную зарплату, потому что боюсь,
что его кто-то схнтит и переманит. Я ему
больше даю. И вот так постепенно он
дорастает до моего партнёра. А что он
делает?
>> Да. А что он делает? Он даёт много и
сразу получает постепенно и помаленьку.
А вот представь, когда человек хочет
получить много и сразу, вот он пришёл и
говорит: "Аривич, дайте зарплату мне
сколько? 5.000". У меня сразу ответ: "А
схераю? Схера ли я тебе должен что-то
давать?" Соответственно, я думаю: "Блин,
уберите этого волонтёра, он ещё ничего
не сделал, уже что-то просит". Мир
устроен так. Сначала ты даёшь, и это в
твоих интересах дать как можно больше,
чтобы он распознал вкус вкус тебя, чтобы
он начал нуждаться в тебе. Поэтому я
всегда говорю: "Сначала для достижения
успеха создайте спрос на себя. Второе,
расширь этот спрос". И вот когда у тебя
появляется большой спрос, у тебя
появляется один из элементов силы под
названием альтернатива. У тебя есть
альтернатива, а у них нету.
>> Угу.
>> И тут начинают расти цены на тебя. Вот.
Вот он и успех.
>> Угу. Супер. Какой бы вы индустрией
занялись?
>> Абсолютно не имеет значения. Я бы
занялся бы той индустрией, в котором
наибольшее количество внимания. То есть
это единственный критерий, по которому я
выбираю, где работать. Там, где
внимание, там и деньги.
>> Внимание - это с точки зрения рынка,
>> это общественное внимание, это хайп, это
общественное внимание, это то, о чём
люди говорят, то, что аа темы каких
конференций наиболее там распростены и
так далее. Но в данном случае сейчас
искусственный интеллект, очевидно же.
Очевидно, где деньги сейчас все деньги
там, где наибольше
там наиболее эффективно карьеру делать.
>> Очевидно, там
>> каких ошибок вы бы точно постарались
избежать?
>> То есть первое больших ошибок. Второе -
это а ошибок с невозвратными потерями.
То есть то, что нельзя вернуть. Это не
всегда про деньги. Это бывает так, что
ты совершил ошибку в отношении какого-то
человека и всё, порвал и больше вернуть
это нельзя. То есть назад это уже не
отыграешь. Угу.
>> Поэтому вот две ошибки, которые я бы
старался избежать. А все остальные
ошибки я бы наоборот старался бы сделать
как можно больше, как можно больше
мелких ошибок и как можно э ошибок с
если там потери
возвратные. А если бы вы заработали
первые деньги, то куда бы вы их
проинвестировали?
>> У меня всегда правила всегда
инвестировать прежде всего в себя. А
даже когда я инвестирую в отдых, трачу
на свой отдых, почему это многие думают:
"А почему это инвестиция?" А потому что
мой основной продукт - это принятие
решений. Так вот, когда я хорошо
отдохнувший, я лучше принимаю решения. Я
принимаю лучшие решения. Поэтому прежде
всего это в себя. Во вторую очередь во
все рычаги, которые я использую, а это
мои ассистенты, это моя команда, это мои
компании.
>> Вы бы делали бизнес в одиночку либо с
партнёром?
>> Я бы предпочёл с партнёром. Более того,
я бы не хотел бы быть главным партнёром.
>> М. А по каким бы критериям вы выбирали
основного партнёра?
>> Я бы выбирал критерии, брал партнёра по
критериям. Во-первых, он должен быть
энергичным. Во-вторых, он должен сильно
вовлечён в то, чем занимается.
А потому что вовлечённость - это
основной распаковщик талантов. Если он
вовлечён, он научится всему. Пускай он
много не знает на старте, но я точно
знаю, что самый лучший способ расти и
обучаться - это делать. Делать то, что
не знаешь. А это возможно, когда ты
любишь то делать, чем ты занимаешься,
когда у тебя высокая степень
вовлечённости.
Ну и третий критерий - это человеческие
качества. То есть наличие совместных
одинаковых ценностей и человеческие
качества, потому что нафиг мне нужен
эффективный партнёр, с которым я не могу
сойтись по жизни.
>> Угу. А по каким бы критериям вы а
набирали первую команду?
>> Набирал свою команду. А, ну прежде всего
это ценности. Ценности. Это команда -
это те люди, которые пришли на мои
ценности. Они разделяют мои ценности. И
поэтому они работают не ради меня. И я
всегда говорю: "Никогда не работайте
ради меня, работайте ради нашей миссии,
которую мы делаем". Поэтому в любой
команде я вообще не ищу лояльность ко
мне, я ищу лояльность к миссии, которую
мы выполняем. Это первый. Второй момент
- это командная работа. Командная
работа, потому что основной смысл
команды - это мультипликация или
синергетический эффект от усилий
каждого. Поэтому отсутствие командной
работы - это всё равно, что человек это
одиночка. Мне не нужны группа волков
одиночек. Условно говоря, один из
мужиков на поле - это просто один из
мужиков. А один из мужиков, которые
распределены по ролям, это команда. Это
уже футбольная команда. Поэтому
командная работа. А для этого опять-таки
моральные ценности и моральные принципы
и ценности. Плюс, э, конечно же, это, э,
его способность адаптироваться.
А адаптироваться - это значит делать,
а принимать ошибки, признавать, улучшать
и двигаться дальше. То есть само
совершение ошибок - это совсем не
показатель. Ну, имеется в виду даже
наоборот хороший показатель. Чем больше
человек совершает мелких ошибок с
обративными последствиями, тем больше он
учится, значит, он больше действует.
Поэтому вот такие основные там их
несколько критериев, но вот основные. Ну
и, естественно, там побочка есть
позитивное отношение к жизни, это
скромность, потому что скромный человек
- это, как правило, командный игрок,
позитивное отношение к жизни. Это
значит, что в любой неудаче он всегда
видит позитивный исход. Ну, то есть это
всё одно к другому, э, ну, одно другое
усиливает.
>> Какой бы вы совет дали самому себе,
период, который был самым сложным в
вашей жизни? А, но смотри, есть такое
понятие ошибка выжившего, когда у
успешного человека спрашивают, а он
говорит про какие-то факторы, что что
ему помогло, да, но в то же время там
9.999 предпринимателей, которые не
выжили, аа они об этом не говорят.
Соответственно, люди слышат только
победителя и думают, что вот это вот это
самое правильное качество, да? А, а я
здесь сделаю наоборот. Так как я
сегодня, слава Всевышнему, нахожусь в
благополучном состоянии и проживаю
счастливую жизнь, значит то, что я
делал, и было самым эффективным.
Соответственно, я бы ничего не менял из
того, что я делал.
>> И у вас есть бизнесы, у вас есть
проекты, а вы там наверняка вместе с
командами строите стратегии, из которых
как-то декомпозируются цели, планы, KPI,
OKR и так далее. И и, конечно же, не все
они реализуются.
>> Неужели ээ это не разочаровывает?
>> Никак,
>> даже если это очень сильно не попало?
>> А вопрос, смотри, во-первых, я учу
команду и настаиваю, чтобы команда не
ставила целью результаты, чтобы команда
ставила целью процесс,
>> потому что правильный процесс всегда
приведёт к правильным результатам.
>> О, какое нечастое мнение. И
разочароваться ты можешь только, если ты
ставишь целью результат.
>> Например, достичь там 10 млн долларов
чистой прибыли, оба и не достиг,
>> да? Да.
>> А если ты выстроил процент, который
делает тебя наиболее эффективно, то в
конце выйдет 10, 12 или 15 или - это
лишь сигнал или обратная связь о том,
что процесс был недостаточно
эффективный. И тогда мы садимся и
разбираемся, где мы могли сработать
лучше и почему не сработали.
>> Угу. Таким образом, для меня ценность
представляет не сам результат. Ценность
для меня представляет обратная связь от
рынка, потому что любой результат есть
обратная связь.
>> Он может быть позитивная обратная связь,
негативная обратная связь.
>> А но это всё сырьё для работы, для
работы в следующем периоде. Наверняка же
были компании в этом году, где резали
бюджеты, сокращали сотрудников, там
увольняли,
увольняли людей, возможно, на которых
там были возложены определённые там
задачи, с которыми они справились. И эти
решения вы принимали сами?
>> Нет,
>> нет, команда,
>> да, это команда принимает. Я я принимаю
решение только про когда инвестирую в
какие-то компании. Ну и, может быть, при
увольнении топ-менеджеров. Ну и то
крайне-крайне редко,
>> потому что я стремлюсь к тому, чтобы
решение об увольнении принимал не я, а
данные.
Если данные показываются, у нас данные м
выставлены таким образом, что в виде
светофора есть данные, э жёлтая красная
зона, жёлтая зона, зелёная зона. Если
компания попадает в жёлтую зону, это
значит ну внимание. А я начинаю звонить,
узнавать. Если в красную зону, то
понятно, что а если квартал держится в
красной зоне и нету тренда на выход,
автоматически вопрос об увольнении.
>> Угу. Но при этом не не фатальный вопрос
там банкротстве компании, да, потому что
если вовремя отреагировать на увольнение
и там сме смотри, банкротство тоже
бывает. У меня в этом году там,
например, один стартап, который я
инвестировал, там 3,3 млн долларов не
выстрелют.
Так,
>> ну и, ну и не выстрелил.
>> Ага. А в Дус Слава, что что был за
>> Они пришли Они пришли ещё за порции
денег небольшой.
>> Ага.
>> А я им дал порцию, небольшую порцию
денег. Ну это буквально там в районе
150.000 долларов на оплату серверов и
закрепил 3 месяца. За 3 месяца при этом
стал поднять цены на все свои продукты в
четыре раза. Он говорит: "Клиенты
убегут". А я говорю: "Какая разница? Ты
так и так банкрот". И будет такое, либо
клиенты молча будут платить, значит, ты
создал крутой продукт, просто ставил
низкую цену, и это это истори твоей
проблемы. Либо действительно клиенты
убегут, ну тогда быстрее поймёшь, что
пациент скорее мёртв, чем жив. И
>> это это не есть там тяжёлое решение. Я
не принимал здесь тяжёлого решения.
Я знал, на что иду, когда инвестировал.
И я знал, какие будут примерно
последствия, с какой вероятностью.
>> Угу. Потому что понятно же, что не все
стартапы выстреливают, там большинство
проваливаются.
>> Что в итоге случилось со стартапом?
>> Ну вот у них, ну до конца года осталось,
>> а процесс ещё идёт.
>> Ну вот ещё ещё месяц остался.
>> Угу. Хочется пару вопросов задать про
сообщество. Мы несколько раз сегодня уже
на эту тему заходили. Вообще, насколько
предпринимателю сейчас важно окружать
себя реальными людьми, несмотря на то,
что у каждого у нас есть телефон, там
какая-нибудь нейроночка, которая доступ
к любой информации, ко всем знаниям мира
в одну секунду нам может предоставить.
Вообще, нужно ли тратить время на
сообщество, на окружение
себя людьми? Если да, то какими людьми?
Но у меня есть такое правило, оно
является слоганом нашего кайзнклуба,
называется возможности и ресурсы для их
реализации приходят через людей. Чем
больше площадь соприкосновения
с реальностью, с людьми, а тем больше
шансов, что тебе повезёт, придёт
какая-то возможность, а и придут ресурсы
для реализации этой возможности. Но
здесь есть одно, но. Это как, знаешь,
я сейчас сказал всё равно, что вот брать
семена и бросать, и они прорастут. Но
если ты будешь бросать на бетонную
почву, там ничего, ну, на бетон ничего
не прорастёт. А если будешь бросать
>> в чернозём, там прорастёт большинство.
Поэтому очень важно выбирать правильные
поля. Поля везения. Это тоже называю
поля везения. Это растущие люди,
растущие сообщества, растущие страны,
растущие отрасли. Поэтому желательно
находиться в сообществе AI
предпринимателей,
находиться в сообществе молодых
предпринимателей, а находиться в
сообществе э тех отрастей, которые
растут и так далее. То есть находиться в
таких сообществах. И здесь очень важно,
что
вот эта среда, она как пишь среда, она
вытягивает человека. Просто ты начинаешь
мыслить, как они действовать, как они
думать, как они, и в конечном итоге ты
становишься как они.
>> Я оба тези хочу поддержать и на моём
опыте, и на опыте участников из нашего
бизнес-сообщества, а, все возможности
приходят от людей, и наличие правильных
людей рядом напрямую влияет на твой
результат, на твой успех, потому что
растём мы тоже об людей. И, друзья, вы
знаете, у нас есть бизнес-клуб
основателя. Мы недавно отпраздновали
[музыка] первый год. А у нас за этот год
были многие наши гости, которые
приходили сначала к нам в YouTube, потом
они приходили к нам в сообщество, потом
на наших конференциях. Вы многих из них
могли видеть, но в сообществе они уже в
закрытом кулуарном формате, в том числе
также делятся своим опытом. Следующий
год будет очень непростым. Вот все, с
кем я общаюсь последние месяцы, от
руководителей корпорации до
предпринимателей малого, [музыка]
среднего бизнеса, все готовятся к очень
серьёзному, очень сложному году. И
проходить сложности [музыка]
вместе с соратниками всегда проще. Нам в
этой части повезло, потому что в нашем
бизнес-сообществе основатели из разных
сфер, из разных рынков, из разных
компаний и с разным опытом, которым эти
люди готовы [музыка] делиться. Поэтому
мне ничего не остаётся, как пригласить
вас пройти следующий год вместе с нами и
сделать инвестицию в себя и в свою
компанию через участие в
бизнес-сообществе основателей. Не скажу,
что будет легко,
а когда было легко, но точно будет проще
и веселее. Ссылка в описании. Оставляйте
ваши заявки. Сайт основаat.org. Мы с
вами свяжемся, чтобы познакомиться,
узнать друг друга получше и, возможно,
пройти следующий год. вместе. Можем ли
мы резюмировать, что, ну, есть некая
формула, которая в большинстве случаев
работ, я [музыка] уверен, что
статистически предприниматели,
которые
могут подтвердить, что они находились
какое-то время в среде более сильных
предпринимателей, не обязательно сильных
с точки зрения там даже
бизнес-результата, а скорее тех
предпринимателей, которые имели тот
опыт, с которым
эти предприниматели ещё не сталкивались.
То есть они могли в буквальном смысле
купить опыт, но за счёт других людей.
>> Ну, смотри, это опять-таки всё зависит
от человека. Всё зависит от человека. И
здесь смотри, а что значит зависит от
человека? А сам человек имеет ответы на
четыре вопроса базовых, фундаментальных,
которые я говорил. Каков этот мир? Кто
я, какой в моём месте? И что я хочу?
Если он не знает ответа на эти вопросы,
то никакое сообщество ему не поможет.
И вообще этот мир - это мир вероятности.
Здесь нету ни белого, ни чёрного. Здесь
есть этот мир, мир полутонов. Мы
существуем в мире вероятностей. Просто
мы говорим, если человек энергичный, у
него вероятность больше, чем не у
энергичного. Дальше, если он в
правильном сообществе, у него
вероятность больше, чем у того, кто не в
правильном сообществе. Дальше, если он
совершает много мелких ошибок, извлекает
уроки, совершенствуется, у него ещё
больше вероятности. И по сути всё, что
ты чем чем занимаешься, ты суммируешь
вероятности в свою пользу, и тогда успех
становится закономерным. Потому что есть
такое понятие, как эргодичность
процессов, который гласит: "Когда ты
собираешь корзину определённых
вероятностей, то результат
гарантирован". Условно говоря, возьмём
обратный пример. Если ты куришь,
то это одна вероятность. Если ты куришь
очень часто, это вторая вероятность.
Если ты куришь часто, плюш пьёшь, пьёшь
часто - это другая вероятность. А если
ты куришь, пьёшь, пьёшь часто и любишь
кататься на мотоцикле - это ещё одна
вероятность. А если ты куришь, пьёшь,
любишь кататься на мотоцикле ночью и
ездить на красный цвет светофора, я
доллар не поставлю на твою жизнь. Угу.
>> Видишь, ты просто накапливаешь.
>> Угу. Поэтому предпринимательство и
движение к успеху - это, на самом деле,
накопление положительных вероятностей в
свою пользу. Весь мир этот, он
вероятностный. И нету поэтому секрета
успеха. Секрет успех не в том, чтобы ты
нашёл какую-то серебряную пулю, а в том,
что ты набираешь корзину вероятностей,
которые с большей вероятностью, но
никогда не 100% приводит тебя к успеху.
и долго находишься в игре.
>> Ну, а продолжительность нахождения в
игре, это как раз-таки влияет на корзину
вероятности. Чем больше ты находишься,
тем больше вероятности в свою пользу ты
набираешь.
>> Угу. У меня, знаете, такая есть теория.
Я, когда начал вести интервью, я очень
сильно увлёкся биографиями, притом людей
из прошлого. Я бы там с удовольствием
взял бы несколько интервью с
предпринимателями там царской России,
потому что там, конечно, есть уникальные
люди, были уникальные люди.
>> И потом у меня появилась возможность с
теми людьми, про которых я раньше читал,
общаться вживую и общаться не всегда под
камеру, потому что, конечно, под камеру
многие, в принципе, не готовы ничего
говорить. И вот я несколько раз себя
ловил на мысли, что когда ты читаешь
некую биографию либо историю,
отшлифованную пиарщиками в какой-то
книге, и она складывается как некая
стратегия, человек вот так вот усердно
работал и работал, но потом ты с ним
знакомишься вживую, и оказывается, что
вот точка перелома происходила, как
правило, в двух вещах. Первое - это
появление в его жизни какого-то
человека, вот абсолютно из другого
уровня, который просто по разным
причинам ему дал, принёс, помог, вытащил
его на свой уровень, притом вообще
по-разному, часто даже не финансовым, то
есть это не какая-то коммерческая
история. А вторая, как как не банально
это звучало, это это реально в нужное
время, в нужном месте ты просто вот
оказался в том рынке, который рос. у
тебя оказался знакомый, который в этом
что-то разбирался, другой знакомый дал
денег, и вот вы как-то вместе бах и
сделали розничную сеть на старте, э там
создания розничного рынка в России,
например, да, либо девелопер,
>> это называю полявезение. Ну вот,
например, ты гений, работаешь 24 на7,
но, условно говоря, где-нибудь в
Таджикистане или тот же самый гений
работает в Силиконовой долине. Ну,
согласитесь, результаты будут разные.
Почему? Потому что они оказались на
разных полях. Все крупные успехи любого
крупного, а, бизнесмена, политика, кого
угодно, они основаны на везении. А
везение - это действие внешних сил. А
проблема в том, что мы с детства
воспитаны не в правильном убеждении. А
мы воспитались, воспитаны в убеждении,
что всё зависит только от нас. И,
соответственно, когда мы ставим цели, мы
сразу начинаем действовать, потому что
мы думаем, что достижение наших целей
является нашей обязанностью. А на самом
деле достижение наших целей не является
нашей обязанностью.
Смотри, правильное убеждение, одно из
которых я обучаю, я просто маленькие
такие показываю фрагментики, чему я
обучаю. Я говорю: "Смотри,
>> для достижения любой цели требуется
определённое количество ресурсов. Это
аксиома, это энергия, время, деньги там
и так далее, связи, определённое
количество ресурсов. Это аксиома.
Большая цель, больше ресурсов, меньше
цель, меньше ресурсов. Так, так. Это
правило номер один. Правило номер номер
два звучит так: это не обязательно
должны быть твои ресурсы. Поэтому это не
значит, что если у тебя нету ресурсов,
то ты не достигнешь больших целей.
Правило номер три. Достижение твоих
целей не является твоей обязанностью.
Вот это основная бомба. Это основной
разрыв шаблона. Люди не понимают, как
такое может быть. Цель же моя. Я говорю:
"Ну и что?" И четвёртое правило я
привожу: достижение твоих целей должно
быть чем-то доходом. И когда достижение
твоих целей является чьим-то доходом,
это не является теперь твоей
обязанностью. Просто ты должен выстроить
такую систему. И мы неправильно
воспитаны, что мы, когда ставим себе
цель, мы сразу же бежим её достигать. Но
смотри, возьмём такой пример. Вот ты
плывёшь в эту сторону, можно взять вёсла
и сразу грясти в ту сторону, а можно
остановиться, поглядеть по сторонам,
выбрать течение, которое течёт в ту
сторону. Вот, пожалуйста, достижение
твоих целей - это уже не твоя
обязанность. Тебя течением несёт туда.
Нужно понять одну базовую вещь. Мы люди,
слишком высокого мнения о себе. Мощь
внешних сил в миллионы раз больше мощи
любого отдельно взятого человека. Ну то
есть в первую очередь надо думать о том,
как использовать внешние силы для того,
чтобы они тебя привели к твоим целям. А
это уже другая парадигма, это другие
действия. Как в своё время Рокфейлер,
по-моему, сказал, по крайней мере, ему
приписывают: "Тот человек, который целый
день занят зарабатываем денег, тот
никогда не создаст богатство". Почему?
Потому что процесс создания богатства -
это другой процесс, другие действия, а
процесс зарабатывания денег - это другие
действия. Я в этом плане бизнесменом,
когда ко мне приходит, говорит: "Я
упёрся в потолок" и так далее, я говорю:
"Для этого ты должен начать делать
что-то другое, либо то же самое, но
по-другому. А это уже другой уровень
мышления". И проблема в том, что все
блага этого мира, все успехи этого мира
на самом деле находятся в нашей голове.
Мы не доиспользуем потенциал нашего
мозга. Мы не недооцениваем,
насколько правильные убеждения и
правильные концепции
имеют эффект на нашу жизнь.
>> У меня один комментарий по поводу
везения. А нет ли в тези, что ему просто
повезло? А часто люди так говорят: "Да,
просто повезло". некого обесценивания,
потому что для того, чтобы ему просто
повезло, он приложил огромное количество
усилий, проявил огромное количество
любознательности, целеустремлённости,
страданий, боли, взял на себя резко
ответственность и, да, ему просто
повезло. То есть он создал какое-то
количество действий, часть из которых
сработала. Но а рассказывая людям о том,
что успех любого человека - это просто
череда как бы обстоятельств, которые
можно обозначить везение, как будто бы
одних обесценивает, а другим это даёт
право пенять вот на эти внешние факторы,
говорить: "Ну я-то здесь живу у себя,
да, э у себя там в пещере". Вот. Потому
что мне не повезло, а другим просто
повезло. Ну вот это есть такое понятие
эффект Данинга Круйгера, когда
неуспешные люди успехи других
приписывают везению, а свои успехи
приписывают себе. А так я как раз-таки
учу,
как создавать условия, при которых тебе
везёт.
Это одно из главных концепций, которые я
объясняю. Дело в том, что
>> везение везение - это что такое везение?
А это событие, прежде всего. Это
события. Плюс твоя сила.
Расшифрую. Смотри,
а каждый день происходит события. Каждый
день происходят миллионы событий, тысячи
событий и так далее. События сами по
себе нейтральные.
Но то, из каких событий ты можешь
извлечь везение или, грубо говоря, как
ты можешь делать так, чтобы событие
сработало в твою пользу, зависит от
твоей силы. А в чём заключается твоя
сила? Во-первых, когда у тебя есть
знание распознать в каком-то событии
возможность, потому что люди в событиях
не видят возможностей, а для этого нужны
знания распознать возможность. Второе, у
тебя должны быть деньги, используют это
событие в свою пользу. У тебя должны
быть связи, использовать это событие в
свою пользу. Так вот, чем ты сильнее,
тем большее количество событий ты можешь
превращать в везени.
>> Угу.
Поэтому вот у меня есть отдельная
концепция определения, что такое сила,
что такое везение и так далее. И я
обучаю именно тому, как делать так,
чтобы
из большего количества событий ты мог
извлекать везение.
>> Угу.
>> И вообще я вывел четыре вида везения.
Есть случайное везение. А оно опять-таки
даже случайное везение, а не полностью
случайно, потому что, условно говоря, ты
можешь вот ходить по лесу, а ну
предположим, ты охотник, хочешь по лесу
и хочешь добыть оленя. Так вот, я тебе
скажу, ты надеешься на случайно взяние?
Ты говоришь: "Да". Я говорю: "Просто,
знаешь как? Пройди в два раза больше
территории леса, чем другой, и у тебя
будет везение больше в два раза".
Потому что случайное везение зависит от
плотности соприкосновения с реальностью.
Чем больше количество знакомых, друзей,
общение и так далее, тем больше у тебя
шансов, что придут везение, хотя оно
случайное. Так вот, есть случайное
везение. Второе, есть везение,
основанное на поиске, когда ты
целенаправленно ищешь возможности.
И третье, есть везение, основанное на
магните, когда ты выстраиваешь такую
ситуацию, при котором везение само идёт
к тебе.
>> Угу.
И четвёртое - это закономерное везение.
Это когда ты используешь,
а, я называю природу вещей. Давай по
порядку. На примере, давай на примере
рыбалки скажу. Например, случайное
везение, когда ты взял удочку, пошёл
первый попаш водоём, забросил и
рыбачишь. Ты не знаешь, на кого
рыбачишь, ты не знаешь, поймаешь, не
поймаешь. Абсолютно случайно. Теперь как
увеличить случайное везение? Ты берёшь
10 удочек, забрасываешь, может быть, в
два разных водоёма, у тебя шансов
больше. Хотя это тоже случайное везение.
Так. Так. Дальше. На основе поиска
везение. На основе поиска. Как это может
выглядеть? Ты, например, одел маску,
взял подводное ружё и плаваешь, ищешь
рыбу. Вот на основе по Чем больше
водоём, большую часть водоёма проплыл,
тем больше тебе везёт. На основе поиска
ты ищешь жирные возможности. Везение на
основе магнита. Когда ты берёшь сетку с
предкормкой, бросаешь, рыба сама
приходит, а потом ты среди них
выбираешь, стреляешь либо ловишь. Рыбаки
что делают? Они же кидают подкормку. Они
эту везение создают
за счёт чего? За счёт магнита. А есть
везение закономерное, когда ты
используешь природу вещей. А что значит
природа вещей? Рыба жива. Жива. Раз она
жива, значит она двигается. А раз
двигается, то она попадёт в сеть.
Поэтому ты берёшь сеть, перекрываешь
водоём, и ты не ждёшь, что она, когда
она проголодается, потому что магнит
зависит от голода рыба, голодна или не
голодна, да? А сеть зависит только от
движения рыбы. Так вот,
>> если она жива, то она двигается, а если
двигается, то она будет у меня. Вот и
всё.
>> Вот это уже закономерное везение,
основанное на природе вещей. И эти
инструменты я обучаю именно этим
инструментом, как это выстраивать в
жизни с практическими конкретными
инструментами. Везение - это не что-то
такое мифическое, это не не что-то такое
там чудо. Вообще чудом люди называют то,
что не когда не могут связать причину
следствия.
Когда люди не могут связать причину
следствия, не видут и не видят
одновременно, они считают это чудом.
Например, я могу почесать затылок, а на
там на стуле появится яблоко. Для тебя
это будет чудо. Ты не видишь
причино-следственную связь. А, например,
это может оказаться так, что я часу чешу
затылок, а это сигнал моему ассистенту
положить туда яблоко. Я пока тебя
отвлекаю, она положила яблоко, ты
смотришь, оно появляется. Опа, но ты
причинно-следственную связь не видишь.
Для тебя это чудо, а для меня это не
чудо,
потому что есть чёткая
причинно-следственная связь. Так вот, в
везении то же самое. есть определённая
закономерность,
и это можно выстраивать. И вот люди,
которые достили больших успехов, я когда
говорю, что они достигли благодаря
везению, это совсем не обесценение их
заслуг. Нет, это просто они неосознанно
делали то, что соответствует тому, что я
говорю. Они неосознанно, может быть,
согласно своим чертам характера
подкармливали людлю людей. Может, он
добрый, щедрый, понимаешь? добрость,
щедрость, благородство привлекает других
людей. Он честный, порядочный,
общительный, открытый. Он привлекает на
себя людей, понимаешь? Либо он
интересный, а благодаря тому, что он
интересный, он создал бренд, и люди на
него идут. Вот он создал магнит,
пожалуйста.
Это же люди неосознанно это делают. А я
вижу, вскрываю это, называюсь, даю
термины, определяю как концепции, а
потом обучаю других людей. Это это
делать осознанно.
Чувствуешь разницу? Одно дело, ты
случайно на этот наткаешься, а другое
дело ты осознанно строишь это.
>> Марглан, спасибо огромное. Мне очень
приятно. Мы, правда, там второй год
думаем о том, что нам надо сделать
что-то с вами, искренне
восхищаюсь теми продуктами, которые вы
делаете,
той просто кладидью знаний, которая у
вас на канале собралась. Это очень
здорово, это очень важно. И вот этот
опыт, а всё-таки вы человек даже через
несколько поколений, которые этот опыт
уже передаёт уже новому поколению. Это
очень круто. И в этой части только
хочется вам пожелать доброго здоровья,
мотивации, энергии продолжать это
делать. Спасибо большо.
>> Спасибо большое. Да, очень приятно
выступить на этом канале, тем более
такая аудитория. Я очень люблю, уважаю
бизнесменов и инвесторов, потому что эти
люди, которые за свой успех платят
деньгами, они несут риск, несут
ответственность. В отличие от политиков,
а те же, условно говоря, мм, деятели
культуры, спортсмены, они рискуют либо
своим телом, либо своим голосом и так
далее, но бизнесмены рискуют гораздо
большим. Они рискуют и своей жизнью, и
жизнью других людей, близких, своих
сотрудников и так далее. Ну
риск и ответственность колоссальная.
Поэтому я очень сильно уважаю
бизнесменов, инвесторов, а тем более
основателей компаний. И у вас название
канала основателей это самая мной
уважаемая и почитаемая аудитория. Таким
людям хочется служить, передавать
знания. Найди своих, найдёшь своё.
Найдёшь своё, найдёшь себя. Вот найти
своих - это вот бизнесмены, инвесторы,
это мои люди. Мне нравится передвой
знания именно им, работать с ними и
чтобы они меняли свою жизнь, свою
реальность. И очень важно, смотрите,
ребята, знания даются только для того,
чтобы менять свою реализ ту сторону,
которую вы хотите. Всё остальное личные
ненужные знания. Относитесь к знанию как
к молотку или плоскогубцам. Всё. То есть
не переоценивайте значение знаний. К
сожалению, у нас куль знаний. Мы
переоцениваем это. Поэтому спасибо
большое за то, что пригласили. Было
приятно было выступить перед этой
аудиторией.
В будущем, конечно, если контент
заслужит право на жизнь, то можешь с
ними второй.
>> Супер. Спасибо огромное.
>> Спасибо.
>> [музыка]
>> He.